He was a comic genius.
You had only one speed setting and that was full throttle for he burst into our
lives as an alien on happy days.
He amazed us with his range of talents.
It's utterly left us breathless.
Yes,
behind the stick of Robin Williams was a man who was deeply play,
goodbye depression.
He had other demons such as alcohol and cocaine as well.
Still,
he kept us entertained to the variant,
which made it all the more unfathomable to his legion of fans and admires me.
Took his life at the age of 63.
In today's biographics,
we intend to get the essence of the real Robin Williams.
Robin mcclaren Williams came into the welds on July the 23rd,
1951 board at Saint Luke's Hospital in Chicago,
Illinois.
He was the only child of Laurie and Robert Williams.
The family was wealthy with Robert to being a senior executive at the Ford Motor
Company.
Laurie was a full model and two part time actress.
Lots of Robin's formative years were spent a loan in the huge mention that was
his home.
In order to cope with his loneliness,
he created characters and conversations in his head.
He was an overweight child which lead to bullying at school.
Sixth grade,
he later recalled was the most difficult year of his life.
Many days he went to crying after constant name calling and physical
harassments.
Each day was torment for him with his only friends,
being the ones he created in his own imagination,
these difficult 20 years.
They brought on a depression that robin was to grapple with for the rest of his
life.
Robin began by using comedy as a defense mechanism.
It started with his mother.
Lori had a very sharp wit and we'd often use humor and laced with sarcasm to
communicate with her son in order to connect with that.
Robin Hanson make his mother laugh.
It wasn't good enough to be Robin.
He had to be funny Robin,
by the time he was 16,
the family had relocated to California where Robin attended redwood high school.
It was the late sixties and the straight laced robin found himself in the middle
of a counter culture that revolved around drugs and sex.
He was able to loosen up on after dabbling with marijuana,
found himself fitting in for the first time.
It was at redwood high that Robin,
he stumbled upon the drama department.
He had already perfected his comedic vanilla quickly establishing a reputation
as the class clown.
He felt totally in love with the idea of Improv performance is comedic
personality slowly emerging through drama classes.
At the same time,
robin got involved in wrestling and soccer proving to be an accomplished
athlete.
Bonds by the time he graduated in 1969,
he was voted by his classmates as least likely to succeed.
Not surprisingly though,
he was also voted funniest students.
After graduating,
he attended Claremont men's college is sites.
They were set on a career in political science before long,
however,
he was spending more time in the college theater when he was in lecture rims.
He won the coveted role of Fagan and the college is production of Oliver Turning
in a performance that made it clear that he was destined for the limelight even
behind his diplomatic ambitions.
Robin involved in a community college has a program during classes.
See what often improvised living as classmates and teachers in fits of laughter.
After three years of honing his craft,
he was offered the opportunity of a lifetime full of scholarship or to the
Julliard School of Performing Arts in New York City.
Robin was one of only two students accepted into the 1973 advanced program that
juilliard the other.
While that was future Superman Christopher Reeve rave,
who would become a close friend,
recalled his first impressions.
Upon meeting Williams,
he wore a tie dye shirts with tracksuit bottoms and talked to Marla minutes.
I'd never seen so much energy contained in one person.
He was like an Untied Balloon that had been inflated and immediately released.
I watched in horror as he virtually chromed off the walls of the class and
hallways.
To say that he was on would be a major understatement.
The juilliard.
Well Robin,
the heat astounded his teachers and fellow students alike.
He was able to take on epicenter of characters with ease,
trading out one accent or dialect for another,
like he was born to do it,
but with the Robin,
he was frustrated at juilliard.
He just didn't fit in.
After two years,
his teachers told him that there was nothing more that they could teach him.
One of his instructors considered robin's via genius.
He was not being properly served by schools conservative in its classical
training style.
He left juilliard in 1976 to launch himself onto the world.
His first stop was the standup circuit on the west coast.
Robin's first break into the realms of comedy.
Okay.
Mr. Club in the San Francisco Bay area,
his first Gig was it the holy city zoo,
where he also spent time tending bar.
These early sides.
They were frantic,
bordering on psychotic.
No one had ever seen anything quite like Robin Williams.
He played a collection of rather edgy characters,
including reverend oral satisfaction is only standup,
was influenced by the likes of Lenny Bruce Peter Sellers and Jonathan winters is
manage quickfire Adlib routines and off the wall,
physical comedy proved an absolute hit anti soon established.
A loyal following.
Robin loves the immediate feedback that came with standup comedy and it was
something that he would continue right through his career despite the apparent
ease of his performances.
He actually found stand up incredibly stressful underneath the cloak of exact.
He wants an intensely shy man.
He once said that he started using drugs and alcohol as a crutch to combat stage
nuts in 1977 when he moved to Los Angeles where he began performing if a comedy
club.
It was here that he was discovered by TV producer George Schlatter,
who offered him a spot in a revival of the old sixties show.
Often now the show,
well,
it ultimately didn't survive,
but for Williams it established a foothold into a career in television.
He became,
they send me regular cast member on the Richard Pryor show while also continuing
perform standup.
It was an appearance on the Richard Pryor show,
the brought Williams to the attention of Gary Marshall,
the producer of the hit Sitcom,
happy days,
often five years.
This scripture,
it says,
while they were running out of ideas they,
they hadn't yet jumped the shark.
They decided to do an episode taking off the 19 sixties Scifi comedy.
My favorite Martian,
the episode when it was called my favorite organ and it called for the costing
of an access to play an alien from the land of Org Marshall Thought Williams
might be the man for the job in one has gone down as possibly the most brilliant
audition in TV history,
rubbing into the room and immediately sat in the chair on his hat.
He continued to do his lines and then broken Zune inspired Adlib Marshall.
It cost him on the spot.
Later commenting that Williams was the only alien who turned up for the part the
episode of happy days.
It was originally shot is a dream sequence on the part of Richie Cunningham.
However,
the character played by Williams mork from ork was such a hit with the TV
watching audience after an initial broadcast that the ending was refilled.
So mark was a real character.
Once your Robbins' work on the happy days episode was improvised and augmented
with physical comedy,
audiences couldn't get enough of the Zany adient and demanded much more.
This led to the creation of the spinoff series,
Mork and mindy,
which ran from 1978 to 1982.
The show catapulted,
Williams do absolute started literally overnight.
After just two weeks on the APP.
It had zoomed to the top 10 of the Nielsen Ratings,
the producers of the show.
They kept the script to loose enough to give robin plenty of room to do as he
pleased,
and the results were unpredictable over the top until areas.
While the critics,
they weren't overly enthused with the show,
they went absolutely falling over themselves to lavish praise upon it.
Star
woke up and it quickly became a pop culture phenomenon.
A generation of kids took to warring mark's Trademark Rainbow suspenders and
greeting their friends with the words no,
no.
Robin went from relative obscurity to instant fame in the space of a couple of
months.
It was something that he was entirely unprepared for and unfortunately it led to
him indulging in the accessories that come with fame,
drugs,
alcohol and women.
Just Nike acted in the fast lane.
He also lived his life and the fastest of fast names.
He quickly slipped into the habit of partying into the early hours,
crawling home at five in the morning,
and then having to be on set by 10:00 AM.
There is no doubt though,
that Robin,
he was blessed with more physical energy than most inevitably.
However,
that energy began to burn out.
He would sometimes fall asleep on the set.
We'll just sit a dormancy in off mode.
One night after performing a late night set at a comedy club,
robin met up with fellow comic John Belushi and ended up at the Chateau Marmont
where Robin's shared some of blue she's cocaine,
and then left the next day on the set of Mork and Mindy Costar.
Pam dawber broke the news to Williams knew she had died of a drug overdose.
The news well that shot him into making significant changes in his lifestyle.
The death of Belushi tarnish the image of Hollywood's fastest living brass pack.
Robyn was called to testify before a grand jury and experience which along with
the shock of Belushi's death and the birth of his first child,
Zach allows him to break free from the strangle hold of drugs and alcohol.
It was at this time that he discovered cycling a form of exercise which you
credits for saving his life.
After four years,
Mork and mindy had lost its midas touch,
produces dried whatever they could to resurrect the initial appeal,
but nothing seemed to work.
They decided to make more,
less naive,
allowing Williams to work in more of his nightclub act material.
Interestingly,
the more character and also founded sway into his standup routines,
though not by Robin's design audience members at late night shows,
we'd simply yell out,
do more,
switch Robinwood,
frustratingly responds,
or mark's not here.
I'm a different guy.
By the middle of 1982,
though,
the character that had propelled Williams to superstar status was beginning to
feel like a millstone around his neck,
so it came as somewhat of a relief to him when mork and mindy was canceled.
After Four Seasons
in 1976,
robin,
Ms Valerie Velarde while working as a bartender in San Francisco.
Shortly after leaving Julliard,
she was a dancer having studied at Julliard herself or they began a relationship
that ends after two years were married on June the fourth,
19,
78.
Valerie,
she endured husbands,
cocaine addiction,
and wild partying lifestyle for a number of years,
as we mentioned the among other things,
it was the birth of his son Zachary on April the 11th,
1983 that have led him to finally shake off his addictions,
our thought that was one thing that he was not able to control that that was his
wondering.
I ended up having an affair with a cocktail waitress by the name of Michelle.
Tish caught up then in 1986 ms dot [inaudible] sued Williams for six point
$4,000,000,
painting that he had knowingly infected with herpes simplex virus.
He settled out of course only for his wife to see if a divorce a few months
later on April the 30th,
1999,
less than a year after his divorce from Valerie being finalized.
Williams married last year.
Grimes,
the form of [inaudible] 92.
His son Zach,
they had actually been carrying on an affair during the last few years.
It was a previous marriage,
but at the time of the wedding last year was pregnant with Robin's trials,
a daughter who they named Zelda Ray.
Two years later,
they had a second child,
cody Allen,
the marriage.
It lasted 19 years,
but Mysia finally left after she realized she wasn't able to handle Robin's
relapse into addiction Williams.
He married for the third and final time in 2011.
This wants to Susan Schneider,
who was a graphic designer at the time.
He met her while recovering from a heart operation in 2009.
They were still together at the time of his death in 2014
robin's fame on the small screen.
It's inevitably arouse the interest of movie makers.
His first starring role came 19 eighties,
Popeye,
the maybe it was a financial amped,
critical flop mentally like Williams is film.
Korea was over before it took really gotten started,
but then in 1982 years,
the world,
according to Garp,
he was able to show more of his dramatic acting talents.
The film,
it was well received with Chris Abbott Calling Robin's performance
unconventional and absorbing,
following a couple of smaller roles.
He got his big screen break in 1987 is good morning.
Vietnam.
This role,
it was Adrian Cron.
Our a real life armed forces dj stationed in Saigon and during the war it was
tailor made for Williams as manic style.
In fact,
nearly everything that he did on screen was totally improvised the performance.
It was good enough to earn him an academy award nomination for best actor over
the next decade.
Williams appeared in an impressive number of films displaying a huge range and
appeal across the generations.
He Sean,
as both a dramatic and to comic actor with his first and only Oscar coming for
best supporting actor playing a psychologist in 1997 is good will hunting.
He had previously received two nominations for 1988 dead poets society in
Nineteen Ninety.
One was the fisher king,
perhaps Williams's most versatile role was one in which he never actually was on
screen,
though it was his role as the genie in the 1992 Disney animated musical Aladdin.
The role had been specifically written them,
although he improvised much of the dialogue just as he had done in good morning
Vietnam Williams.
When told to play what would be his most beloved character in 1993 is mrs
doubtfire.
In this movie,
he portrayed a recently divorced actor who takes on the persona of an elderly
Scottish housemate to get closer to his children.
He spent four hours everyday putting on his makeup to play the part while the
movie.
It was a great success.
Sunday sequel was actually in the works at the time of Williams,
his death in 2014.
His darkest role again in 2002.
One hour.
Photo Williams played a lonely photo technician.
He becomes obsessed with a family he photos he has developed for years.
He received rave reviews from such esteemed critics is then at Melton and
Abbott's.
Robin's last parents on the big screen was in 2014 night at the museum secret of
the team in which he reprized his role as President Theodore Roosevelt in the
2015 film.
Absolutely anything.
He provided it.
The Voice of dentists,
the dog.
It's closed out a 38 year career that encompassed 74 movies
in 1966 together with fellow celebrity will be Goldberg and Billy Crystal.
Robin founded Comic Relief Usa.
The PRC helps the homeless with $80 million dollars being raised as of last
year.
Together with his second wife,
he also created the windfall foundation to help donate money to a variety of
causes including some jude children's research hospital.
On May the 27th,
19,
55.
Robin's close friend Christopher Reeve was thrown from a horse and it's
paralyzed.
Robin drops everything and rushed to get his bad side.
He turns up in full costume as a crazed Russian doctor giving rave at the first
loft.
Since it's tragic accidents,
robin would go on to donate huge sums to research and to spinal cord injury.
When reeves died into counseling and forth,
robin was absolutely devastated.
Williams was also passionate about supporting the military.
He traveled and performed at many bases around the globe and he was well known
as a modern day.
Bob Hope.
During his career,
he entertained over 100,000 troops in 13 countries.
Williams managed to quit alcohol and cocaine in the early 19 eighties,
however,
in 2003,
he lapse back into alcohol abuse while working on the movie,
the big white or location in Alaska for the next three years.
He denied that he had a problem.
Finally,
he was confronted by family and friends who convinced him to check himself into
a substance abuse rehabilitation center in Newburg,
Oregon,
and then he finally admitted that he was an alcoholic after 60 days in Rehab,
rather than responding to his family,
robin began living with a sober companion who was charged with ensuring that he
didn't relapse.
It was shortly after that that his wife,
Marcy,
I left him a depressed robin,
did what he always did to get to by when life got tough,
he threw himself into his work going on tour to do stand up,
but unfortunately in the middle of this tour,
it was discovered that he needed heart surgery.
The operation,
it went well,
but it required quite at rest in order to recuperate.
This forced time of inactivity allowed the demons in his head to have free rein.
Williams is addictive.
Personality led to marathon cycling and video gaming sessions.
Cycling was a healthy obsession for him,
but for a man who struggled with depression his whole life,
the Ng alone in a room with a computer was very dangerous.
Shortly after this,
he began drinking again.
This time we didn't care who knew in May of 2014 Williams,
his new TV show,
the crazy ones was canceled after just one season in July and he was back in
Rehab.
It was around that time that he also learns that he had Parkinson's disease.
After his death,
it was discovered that what had been diagnosed as Parkinson's was actually lewy
body dementia.
After his death,
Robin's wife Susan revealed that Robin had been having severe runs,
prolonged episodes of fear and anxiety,
insomnia,
constipation,
stress,
and having friends that have been going on for over a year.
She said that he would constantly tell her,
I just want to reboot my brain.
On August the 11th,
2014,
Robin Williams committed suicide by hanging himself with bells.
He died from asphyxiation.
His wife,
Susan,
stated that he was killed by a terrorist and signed my husband's brain.
Within hours of the tragic news of his passing,
thousands of fans were posting images of themselves,
standing on their desks with the caption,
oh,
captain,
my captain in reference to Robin's character in dead poets society.
It was a fitting tribute and to beautiful.
Stand off to this brilliant man,
so I really hope you found that video interesting and inspiring.
If you did,
please do that.
Thumbs up button below and don't forget to subscribe.
We've got brand new videos on this channel.
Biographies of all sorts of people from history,
whether Robin Williams to all sorts of different things from politicians,
serial killers,
business people are running the gamut.
Anyway,
you can check out some more of those that are over there on the right and don't
forget to subscribe.
I'm thank you for watching.